maya bay thailand is known the world
over as the impossibly beautiful
location for the 2000 movie the beach
tony's been talking about it all morning
long
it is one of the most instagrammable
places on earth but its jagged cliffs
and turquoise waters attracted millions
of tourists who ruined the bay and its
marine life now after being closed for
more than three years maya bay has
reopened with a makeover for the social
media age elizabeth palmer went to take
a look
until the year 2000 maya bay was a
tranquil jewel just off the coast of
thailand
and then leonardo dicaprio showed up to
star in the movie the beach all in all
this really was paradise
except for one thing
desire is desire
wherever you go
it kicked off a flood of tourists which
soon spelled disaster for maya bay
jostling tour boats mobs of sightseers
and swimmers covered in sunscreen
brought noise litter and pollution that
destroyed the bay's marine life
faced with out of control boat and
tourist traffic and dying coral reefs
the thai government made the hard
decision to turn maya bay basically from
a beach into a backdrop
first they closed it for three and a
half years to let nature recover and
then rewrote the rules to protect the
environment and give tourists what they
want trophy pictures
emily's family and friends in new york
will be able to see her in maya bay by
this evening now we live in a time where
social media is just like who has the
best pictures so i was super excited
boats are now barred from the bay
passengers arrive at the back of the
island and then follow a boardwalk to
the beach where the new rules
are enforced by wardens
this is my obey reimagined for the
social media age
but no one's complaining they're too
busy getting the perfect shot
jason understands it's a trade-off as a
tourist you want to be able to see these
cool sites but at the same time we
definitely leave a footprint that
is uh having a negative impact
warden southampton tells me he's
expecting a busy spring 375 people an
hour
11 hours every day
that's
4 000 people
4125 people for one day
today's crowds are about half that and
already it feels busy we're still in
covid pandemic yeah so when you really
open up yeah it's just going to be
non-stop
is it working well early signs say yes
it is the coral is slowly recovering
and reef sharks which hadn't been seen
for years are back
as post-pandemic travel picks up again
maya bay is an experiment in mass
tourism that doesn't love nature to
death
for cbs mornings i'm elizabeth palmer in
maya bay thailand
i'm not digging it what is happening in
the world yes so you can go but don't
get a kid it's not a beach it's a
backdrop
you can stand in front of it and you can
pose but you can't get wet no thanks i
mean we
can't have nice things yeah it's like we
can't have nice you can't have nice
things it's like giving you something
really delicious and say no you can't
you can take a picture with the food but
you can't eat it that's a very good
analogy it was very pretty painful wow
very very pretty